le fond à la pause et un discours qui
montre bien sa personnalité et la
différence de sa personnalité avec
monsieur macron une femme courageuse une
femme engagée et sur le fond la nouvelle
france en terme d'autorité de travail de
territoire franchement aux antipodes
c'est un vrai projet qui permet la
confrontation entre les uns et les
autres c'est la droite de l'ordre
c'est la droite des valeurs
républicaines c'est la droite du travail
et c'est aussi la droite de la
république des territoires allant même
plus loin de la révolution par les
territoires elle est la seule à porter
ses idées et c'est celle qui remettront
qui permettront de remettre la france
sur les rails de redonner de la
confiance et de la fierté à nos
consultants et tout ça elle l'a dit
dimanche et tout ça elle l'a bien dit
aliments sur le travail sur le fait de
pouvoir dépasser sortir des 35 heures de
pouvoir acheter les journées de rtt ce
que valérie veut mettre en place
justement sur la politique familiale ce
sont des solutions pour les classes
moyennes parce que cinq ans après
l'élection de monsieur macro les classes
moyennes ont perdu espoir elles n'ont
pas le sentiment c'est la réalité du
déclassement et nous nous voulons leur
donner confiance il y en a c'est le
président des gens qui vont très bien
tant mieux pour eux mais valérie va être
la candidate de tous les français mais
de dire que la priorité ça sera pour les
classes moyennes à questions